we went turkey hunting this weekend and
uh we went with Michael wiell and so you
bring up a picture of Michael wiell
there Riley
Ma back there beating off
huh no I don't know if he's that guy
really let's get to a picture there
Michael
wadell
bro that's male Whittle okay
that is not how you [__]
[Music]
spell no wad l w this
guy this guy looks like a [__] nut
sack sorry to say that he don't look
like a full one but he looks like a
couple parts of it kind of put
together there you
go nope damn W boy w a d d e l
l there we go we went out there with
Michael wadell and now this dude hates
turkeys is I don't say he's the AMA Bin
Laden of T turkeys dude yeah yeah he's
Osama Butterball Laden dude this guy so
we get out there would you think of it
man what' you think of the hunting well
I I thought it was uh I thought it was
5050 was 50% fun 50% very very boring
terribly boring and 50% really fun yeah
I like the parts where the part this
thinks about hunting I thought is like
you you're out there and you kind of
think of it as like a chill Vibe where
you're with your boys you're maybe
popping a beer talking listening to
music but you can't drink because you
have guns there's no music because you
have to be quiet and then half the time
my boy you were in the car yeah yeah
well I would don't throw me into the car
you were okay dude when I I got turkey
and you were in the car well let's tell
everybody exactly what happened so first
of all we go out there all right and you
set up you bring like these little
tricks and stuff you bring like little
like fans that are like uh camouflage
little and you're like just Gaya girl
and out there in the field like trying
to hide behind his
fan and you kind of set like you go set
up and you hide somewhere and Michael's
also like to set it up like the number
one turkey hunter in the I guess world
oh yeah this guy could yeah I mean this
guy could just shoot an arrow into the
air and it would land in a turkey he won
like a competition turkey calling
Nationals yeah he was like yeah he's
like one of the best turkey callers ever
so he's got that uh he's got that verbal
on him you know he's
definitely he's I mean he's a uh he's
like the pavara of turkey turkey cers so
he gets out there so you're kind of
setting up and then he's he's like in
the distance he's like
uh
do it see if you can do
it he gave me the thing I wish I brought
it we could have call we could have used
it I know showed for real the funniest
thing is he'll be like all right
everyone be real calm these guys eat
they eat ants and dirt for they can see
every Speck of dirt that's what they eat
for a full time job like yeah they eat
spiders buddy so if they can see that
they can see you so they have amazing
eyesight to be that's the thing you have
to sneak up on so we're all sitting dead
still cuz he's telling us and then
meanwhile he's running through the
field he's got the [__] fan
going like dude they can see you for
sure so he's a fake turkey and he holds
a fake turkey in front of him they can't
see him because he's hiding behind this
fake turkey that's about this Big's
holding in front of him like an
invisibility cloak yeah yeah we had like
Five Guys hiding behind a little bitty
fake tur like it was crazy so but anyway
the crazy part for me is and first of
all I'll tell you why I was in the car
so we did a couple of we did a couple of
spots where you make the calls and
everything nothing showed up right it
was like waiting for like it's almost
like if you order Uber Eats or something
and then it just doesn't show up or
whatever the guy's lost at a certain
point it's like ah [__] it I'll just go
put something in the oven but sometimes
we would see them like it would be like
if you saw uach it's got close to your
house so you go outside to grab it and
he kind of just creeps up and then just
drives past your house
yeah they had all types of like so
anyway so the turkey you go out there
and you make the sounds and stuff and we
couldn't get the we didn't get a member
we didn't get them no so we had retired
for the day the first day yeah like two
hours we were we we out there two or
three hours and we said that's enough
right at that point we all got in the
truck and we were leaving and at that
point we just drove past a bunch of tur
like we'd been in the woods looking for
turkeys well de was like I saw some
gobblers over there yeah so there's
another guy that was with us and he's
like a I guess he's like a land man you
know he kind of is like a you know part
man part myth he kind of hangs out at
the camp you know this fell named de was
his name and that's not a full I guess
it's not a whole name but it's he gives
you half of it you know what I'm saying
he ain't he keeps his cards close to you
kep saying dyslexic ad I don't know what
it stood for I thought it was Ed but he
had the letters tangled up but uh so we
get out there and then we're riding off
and de goes I seen I think I've seen a
couple gobblers okay and uh so gobblers
are turkeys I guess right so there's
always everybody saying oh there's a
couple gobblers right around that bend
over there it's a buzz word for sure
yeah it's a buzz
word and so it's like saying Synergy in
the business
meeting yeah or saying zeit gist people
always say oh it's in the zit gist you
know um so anyway somebody pop
somebody's like oh s a couple gobblers
over there so next you know know we
drive past like a bunch of turkeys and
they were like I guess they were like on
break or whatever cuz I guess the
turkeys are like out like trying to hide
from us and then they all take a break
anyway we get we we went we couldn't
find any turkeys that morning so we're
leaving and there's a bunch of turkeys
just like they're like resting their
legs on the side of the road some of
them are sitting in ice tubs they're all
like it's behind the scenes we're
driving through like behind the scenes
turkey BTS dude yeah yeah turkey BTS so
they're like all right let's go get one
of these goers all right so they got
these guys are like all right we're
gonna go get one because Michael wadell
does not like he don't let a turkey live
he don't want to let a turkey live he is
when he locks in on a bird he locks in
on a bird he's very very very nice and
very very charismatic to people but he's
that you can see does have that switch
oh it [__] switches after three hours
we're like maybe let's go back and get
some breakfast because we've been up
since 4:40 in the morning and he was
maybe we stay here yeah kill these
[__] turkeys okay hey dude we'll stay
around for another minute yeah dude he
won't I mean if you even [__] mention
Thanksgiving he'll just [__] come on
you yeah you know he on saying all these
turkeys want to do is [__] fight I
was like yeah is it just the turkey who
we talking about
dude so anyway they we parked the truck
you guys get out and go back into some
woods and come back a few minutes later
with uh what happened dude the turkey
walked up on us like I mean this sounds
crazy it was probably seven yards away
from me oh but dude what are you going
to do like we have been waiting all day
we go out there we drive all the way to
amach Florida Which is far for everyone
we're doing a hunting trip we've been
planning it for six months we're wearing
camo woke up at 4:40 in the morning yeah
I'm holding a gun we're looking for
turkeys and I see one seven yards away
what am I supposed to do dude seven put
the rifle down yeah I don't know no look
man you guys went and did it for me it
was just like we done it we're leaving
we see a bunch of turkey talking playing
like they were playing like bad M on the
side of the road so then it's like all
right let's go kill one of these
bastards like oh y they someone threw me
a peace sign one yeah yeah they're not
yeah it was like they they seemed a it
was like I don't know I felt like the
hunt had kind of ended a little bit for
that morning it had um and then also the
thing about turkeys is dude these
turkeys are they're two years old bro
well they're fully mature that's what he
that's what he told me I don't really
know but he said two years old is fully
mature turkey he's ready to die that's
what he
said but can he buy so he can serve his
country but can he buy a beer is what
I'm asking okay but it I just felt that
was the part for me was a little sick
like if like what if there was a
two-year-old kid out there and you
hiding in the distance right making
sounds you know like oh give me that
back you know or no it's nap time you
start making [__] and he comes over and
and then you shoot him with a [__]
gun that's the part for me that wasn't
adding up man it was like you do all
this trickery to get them to come over
and then they're only two years old it's
deceptive it's a deceptive business yeah
and then you literally blow the bird
yeah we blew blew the bird's brains out
yeah it was there was some sad parts to
it yeah also dude when I shot that rifle
the whole time my only concern it wasn't
a rifle it was a shotgun the only
concern I had cuz I think that was the
only time in my life I've ever shot a
shotgun I never shot a shotgun I can't
think of one time that I've done it and
my only concern was I had shot other
guns like the range or whatever MH and I
was thinking every time I got earplugs I
was like is this going to be loud like
don't we need earplugs and I was like no
no no you're good D I shot that thing
dude it sounded like a a bomb went I was
like for like 3 hours the next day we
went back I wouldn't even hold a gun my
ear was hurting so bad when you're going
to hold a gun like these guys are insane
and I said that to him like oh yeah we I
was like we can't even really hear that
good anymore I was like he probably
can't hear me right now and he literally
said he literally said
what oh we're going to get some
gobblers yeah it was loud that's how I
describe it was loud but we ate him so I
think that makes it like oh they cooked
it up immediately and now look I mean it
was a great experience it was awesome it
was like it was you know I didn't know
what it was going to be like you know I
mean you go out there you kind of set
up I think I I've always want to fight
something hand to hand so I think I it
would to me it seems like if if I got a
blade on me or a sword even I would go
out there and fight a a turkey but I
think you know I think the little bit of
like let me hide behind this tree yeah
and make a sound of another you know
yeah young animal and we didn't say this
but the sound is like
so it's it's basically a horny bird yeah
like we're supposed to be a hen we're
pretending to be a hen right trying to
seduce a horny uh Turkey right that's
like say you're at a rest area right and
you go in the there's some dude out
there smoking against the wall right
he's out there just smoking a cigarette
and you go inside the men's restroom or
the women's right and the window he's
smoking right outside of a window that
get where you can inside of the restroom
now and you're like oh come out come
come on in here and get this Cooter baby
you know come on in here and uh and uh
just slide up on up in this slick wallet
you know you say [__] like that right
yeah and at first he's thinking oh
that's some [__] in there that ain't
real he keeps puffing his [__]
Winston out there and then finally
you're just like you just start yelling
like Oh Come and just snack on these
titty nipples you know and finally put
that cigar out is like all right I'm
enough yeah and then right when he comes
in yeah you [__] blow his brains
out yeah I would have liked to have got
one I would go again and do it um I
think who you take and who you go with
is definitely one of the best things
when I went to sat in the car uh it was
just me and de in there okay so we're in
we're at the house I think you were
outside yeah and I was sitting inside
and everyone had been talking and it was
kind of a situation we all moving around
go inside outside take a break from the
conversation go back out cuz you know we
talking about
some sometimes you walk away and you
come back it is what it is and he walked
in I think he had just dropped this bomb
on you guys and he liked the reception
he got outside so he came in he's like I
gotta get out of there they're talking
about they're talk they're going way too
deep and I was like what what are they
talking about and then he just dropped
it on me too but it was kind of a good
point he was like all right so the Bible
mhm he's like you got the Bible you got
Adam yep he did it to you too you got
Eve mhm you got their two sons mhm
where' all other people come
from Big Talk how do you get the Chinese
how you get Japanese
blacks
Mexicans other people that's and I was
like uh and I was like yeah wait how did
that happen
I looked up the biblical family tree and
it's it's uh Adam you got Adam yeah you
got Eve you got your three
sons where did the other people come
from yeah where'd you get that next
gobler you know what I'm
saying hope you enjoyed that video and
you can watch another and you can watch
this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two
options watch one this one or this
one